[Applause]
Morant with a nice crossover left it
short
ashimura fouled in a crowd
and took exception to that last hit
[Applause]
so I don't blame him being upset here
there was some contact that I would
object to as a basketball player are you
coming downhill full speed if somebody
hits you in the back
that is objectionable very hard to
regain your balance here I need to see
this again
there's a foul okay that was honshar and
then he took exception to Roddy a little
bit of that left arm push in the
aftermath I mean the first one
you know you're making a play okay
but it's a little bit at the end there
that I think he objected to and Roddy is
just sitting there saying that's my
momentum
and now we get this
and think about it it really is about
his personality it sort of stayed very
good yep
hey you don't see him emote a whole
bunch
but this series is getting a little bit
safer yeah
laughing it up with Malik Beasley
Darvin the former player
if you can smile about it right now when
you look at the scoreboard I I don't
when I saw this live I was like I don't
like that play I feel like it looked
dangerous that's that's somebody trying
to make a play yeah that was just a back
tap attempt at when arrived and I'll be
on the same thing I thought here like
was that a little excessive but looking
at it slowly yeah I'm like ah and you
know what Doris you actually at times
have to defend after the whistle so you
don't prevent a potential three-point
play you never know what the official is
going to allow in Wake of a foul call so
you know Roddy there in his defense just
knocking the ball away yeah and I again
on first look before I saw these replays
I was like wow that's two in the back
yeah I'd be annoyed as well
[Applause]
just got on my last nerve right there
you see Ronnie looks a little bit
surprised like hey you know he didn't
know why Ruby was coming after him
[Applause]
had an unsportsmanlike reaction to the
foul he'll be assessed a technical foul
technical foul
hachimuro common file contract
there it is stunned hashimura
[Applause]
so I'm trying to try to figure out why
it went the way it did
an unsportsmanlike reaction causing a
technical foul in Bane
makes the free throw
the Lakers still puzzled
quizzical with 123 to go in the third
quarter I gotta be honest when he sees
the post game as a basketball player you
get hit in the back as you're going
downhill especially near the rim you're
thinking what the heck here that's
dangerous I think if he looks at the
film
his reaction wouldn't have been the same
if he saw the way it developed do you
know what I mean right
[Applause]
yeah knocks down the free throw the lead
back up to 19.
biker shooting 46 percent from the field
in the game just four of 17 from deep
and
LeBron's minutes on the light side so
far tonight the result of the huge
margin